What if Zoro killed every pirate he came across
to buy himself a place amongst the celestial
dragons? What if Franky used his blueprints to
turn himself into the ancient weapon Pluton?
And what if Luffy was the one who stabbed Ace
in the back to become one of the Warlords? In
other words: What would it look like if
the straw hat pirates were truly evil?
Believe it or not, Jinbei was first introduced
all the way back in chapter 69 (nice),
by Zoro’s bounty hunter friends when
they talked about the seven warlords..
According to their highly inaccurate
silhouettes, these monstrous pirates
were feared throughout the Grand Line. And
just a few chapters later, Dracule Mihawk
confirmed their power when he cut a massive
ship in half and then nearly cut Zoro in half.
Of course, when we’re finally introduced to
Jinbei, we find out he’s actually just a big,
cuddly Teddy…Shark…Guy…but what would it have
taken for this fearsome fishman
to have turned to the dark side?
Well, not much actually. In fact,
Arlong shared a backstory with
Jinbei and just look at how he turned out.
After their mentor, Fisher Tiger’s, death,
Arlong cursed humans and sought violent revenge
for all the discrimination that the Fishmen
faced. Jinbei walked a difficult, but noble
path, in honoring Fisher Tiger’s legacy and
deciding to become a Warlord for the greater
good of Fishman Island’s future. However,
Jinbei could have taken the easier way out just
like Arlong. He wouldn’t just want peace for
Fishman Island - he’d make Fishman Island a world
power in his conquest for revenge against humans.
Jinbei and Arlong could have sailed together as
Co-Captains of the New Sun Pirates, “shining a
light” on the misdeeds of humans throughout the
Grand Line and generally terrorizing the globe
together. Using Fishman Karate, Jinbei would cut
down ships, leaving marine soldiers and civilians
alike to drown in the dreadful waters of the
world’s most dangerous ocean. Unfortunately,
this would have caused the World Government to
pass judgment on Fishman Island and after a hard
fought battle against the admirals, Arlong and
Jinbei both would have ended up in Impel Down.
This time, when Luffy finds Jinbei in Level 6 of
Impel Down, he’d actually deserve to be locked up
there. If the humans of the One Piece world would
treat him like a monster, then he’d act like one.
The same goes for another monstrous member of
the Straw Hat Crew: Chopper. As a reindeer who
ate the human-human fruit, Chopper was shunned
by the rest of the reindeer in his herd for
being different from everyone else. However,
even though he developed human intelligence,
the villagers of Drum Island feared him as a
beast. He finally found hope, though, in the
form of his mentor Dr. Hiruluk who helped
him find his dream of becoming a doctor.
However, once Dr. Hiruluk died, Chopper
was devastated. Not only that, but he
felt largely responsible for his mentor’s
death, having given him a poisonous mushroom,
thinking it would heal his disease.
Imagine if Dr. Kureha had refused Dr.
Hiruluk’s request to take in Chopper
and teach him medicine - or worse,
if Wapol’s army had successfully found and
executed her like he did with the other doctors
who wouldn’t join his private medical team. Man,
thinking about the Drum Island arc, it really
might be the only country that has even more
restrictive healthcare than the United States.
In this Dark Timeline, Chopper would
be left to fend for himself in the cold
winter wilderness of Drum Island. Residents
of the island’s villages would spread rumors
of a beast wandering the snows at night.
They’d warn against going out after dark,
for the monster would come into the
villages to scavenge for food or supplies.
And what would those supplies be for?
Well, just because Dr. Hiruluk died,
it doesn’t mean Chopper would lose his
intelligence and curiosity. He’d still
be experimenting with chemistry, but this
time wouldn’t just become knowledgeable
in medicine - he’d learn how to manipulate
poisons and other dangerous substances. He
would also not follow the same code of ethics
when practicing medicine and would be fully
willing to experiment on living subjects in order
to develop medicines. When he saw Caesar Clown
experimenting on children at Punk Hazard,
he would simply say “hell yeah, brother.”
He would also still use science to experiment
on his own devil fruit transformations using
the rumble balls, which would allow Chopper
to become a true beast by accessing Monster
Point. Using this power, he’d reduce Wapol’s
castle to rubble and become the de facto ruler
of the island. In fact, Oda hints that this
is what would happen to Chopper in a darker
timeline. In the SBS sections of the manga
volumes, he’s drawn alternate futures for
most of the Straw Hats - and Chopper’s shows
him as a grotesque beast demanding sacrifices.
When Luffy and his Evil Crew finally showed
up, they’d think a beast like Evil Chopper
would fit right in on their crew of
monsters - and Chopper would take the
opportunity to find more knowledge, poisons,
and sacrifices all across the Grand Line.
Also joining the Evil Straw Hats on a quest
for knowledge would be the Devil Child,
Nico Robin. After defeating the Warlord Sir
Crocodile and claiming the Kingdom of Alabasta
as his own territory, Luffy would recruit Robin to
his side. Miss All-Sunday had proven herself to be
a capable and cunning fighter, had saved Luffy’s
life in the hopes he would defeat her employer,
and came with the added bonus of knowing
how to read the poneglyphs, which were said
to reveal the secrets of the Ancient Weapons -
knowledge that could turn the world upside down.
Nico Robin had spent her life on the run from the
government, always sticking to the side of the
strong in order to save herself. When a rising
star showed the potential to become the next
pirate king, it would be natural for this lifelong
criminal to join his crew. In this timeline,
we’d sadly never see the kinder, gentler Robin
that opened up to the Straw Hats. Instead,
she would silently follow along with the crew
in order to meet her own goal of uncovering the
secrets of the Poneglyphs. Once she accomplished
her dream of uncovering the true history,
what would she do? Well, she’d take the
secrets about the Ancient Weapons and use
them to destroy the World Government. If they
thought the Buster Call on Ohara was justified,
just wait and see what destruction she could
cause with the Ancient Weapons at her disposal.
When CP9 steals Robin away, the crew wouldn’t
save her because she’s their treasured friend.
They would do it because she’s their key
to reaching the end of the Grand Line,
sought after by every major
pirate crew and the marines alike.
While it’s tragic that Robin would spend
the rest of her life quietly suffering,
the bright side for us is that she’d keep the
cowboy hat and Uma Thurman bangs for way longer.
Our next character wouldn’t be quietly
suffering. He’d actually be very loudly
suffering. He’d turn his suffering up to
11, because making noise is his whole deal.
Brook’s entire crew died horrible deaths
while their ship was trapped inside the
Florian Triangle. Thanks to his devil
fruit, he then found himself inhabiting
his own decayed skeleton. He was no longer flesh
and blood. He was a shadow of his former self,
and then even that was stolen from him by
Gecko Moria. That’s enough to drive anyone mad.
When the Evil Straw Hats™ would find themselves
in the shrouded mists of the Florian Triangle,
they’d encounter this skeleton
and immediately demand that he
join their. Just like Luffy immediately took
a liking to Brook, he would immediately want
a cool skeleton on his crew. His face
perfectly matches their Jolly Roger.
Brook’s dream is to eventually reunite with
Laboon. But having gone completely insane,
Evil Brook will only want to do so because
he’s pulled a complete Captain Ahab (except
instead of losing his leg, he’s lost all of
his skin). In his mind, twisted by loneliness,
he would think that Laboon had abandoned
him - his last friend alive leaving him
to suffer in the Florian Triangle. With
his new signature weapon, The Guitarpoon,
in hand - he would take out Laboon and
then sell his blubber for huge profits.
In this timeline, Bink’s Sake wouldn’t
just be a song for fun parties. For the
Straw Hats’ enemies…it would
be the last thing they ever
hear. Brook isn’t the only Straw Hat
that would cease to be alive, either.
In Franky’s dark timeline, as drawn by Oda, he
goes beyond being a cyborg who’s augmented his
body into making himself fully a machine. Just
like Dr. Vegapunk did to Kuma, Franky would use
his mechanical know-how to turn himself into the
ultimate weapon: The Battle Franky 50. In Oda’s
dark timeline drawing, he looks like his main body
has just become the General Franky - and he says
the foreboding line that he must eliminate all
ships. This would make him the perfect addition
to the Straw Hats’ crew - as they traveled across
the Grand Line, he would sink the ships of the
rival warlords, supernovas, and emperors
alike in his mission to destroy all ships.
When the Straw Hats originally met Franky, he
was a crime lord in Water 7 leading his own gang.
Instead of having a redemptive arc when he meets
the Straw Hats, when he meets the #Evil Straw Hats
he would just fit right in just as he was. But
eventually, he’d do something even better than
building the Straw Hats the Thousand Sunny. Oda
gives us another version of Franky 20 more years
down the line where he’s turned himself into not
just a cyborg - but into the ultimate battleship:
The Battle Franky 70. He wouldn’t just build a
ship worthy of the Pirate King - he’d BE the ship.
And this evil version of Franky would
have no reservations against utilizing
the Pluton blueprints that had been passed
down to him. It’s like that Battleship
Franky would have the destructive power
of an Ancient Weapon built into him. And
since the Evil Straw Hat crew would then
essentially be using Pluton as their ship,
they would be able to lay waste to anyone in
their path as they sailed to find the One Piece.
Of course, to sail the Battleship Franky through
the Grand Line, this crew will need a navigator:
Cat Burglar Nami is already motivated by greed
- she craves riches and treasure like the pirate
she is. And since she had years of experience on
the crew of the infamous Arlong, she’ll still fit
right in on the Evil Straw Hat crew. Once Luffy
gave Arlong a beating, Nami would know that if
she really wanted to make bank - for her own
gain, not to buy back Cocoyashi, then betting
on Luffy would be the right move. After all, with
monsters like Luffy, Zoro, and Sanji on the crew,
all she’d have to do is lay back and steer
the ship while the treasure came flowing in.
In this version of the Straw Hats, Nami would be
true to her name. Even though she’s called the Cat
Burglar in her Wanted Posters, she’s rarely used
her skills of stealth and infiltration. In fact,
other Straw Hats like Robin and Brook have
taken the stealth missions instead. This
Nami, however, wouldn’t just be in charge
of getting the Straw Hats to their next
destination. She’d be robbing those
destinations blind and then going on
shopping sprees to fill every spare room of
the Battleship Franky with lavish luxuries.
But what about Nami’s love of navigation and
map-making? Well, she learned something from
her evil mentor Arlong. It’s a whole lot easier
to have someone else do the work for you. She
could use those riches she stole to simply pay
someone to make maps for her. Or better yet,
she can just chain them up and force them
to do the work. Meanwhile, she can just sit
back and relax while eating only the decadent
dishes prepared by her personal chef: Sanji
Oda’s drawings for a dark timeline
Sanji are fascinating. In the first one,
he stops caring about how gourmet his dishes
are - instead, he thinks all food is the same
as long as it fills your belly. Even though
this is a huge shift from his current mindset,
we feel he’d still pull out all the culinary
stops for Nami because his love for every
beautiful woman isn’t going to change in even
the darkest alternate universe. Once he finally
found the All Blue, Sanji wouldn’t use it to
create the ultimate seafood dishes - instead,
he’d start a commercial fishery, destroying
the All Blue’s ecosystem and using the
funds to support his Evil Empire - because
Evil Sanji has a whole Kingdom to inherit.
Oda also drew an even older version of Sanji that
has more terrifying implications. In a timeline
where everything goes wrong, Sanji doesn’t
deny his Vinsmoke name, he embraces it. This
picture has Sanji looking exactly like his father,
Vinsmoke Judge. He’s grown out his mustache, which
will now be perfect for twirling villainously. As
a member of the Evil Straw Hats, he’d overtake his
family for control of the Germa Kingdom. The
only thing scarier than seeing the Battleship
Franky coming toward you…would be the Battleship
Franky followed by hundreds of giant Germa snails.
And leading that massive fleet (including at
least 8000 men) under the Straw Hat banner
would be Captain Sniper God King Usopp,
the master manipulator. Usopp’s greatest
strength - other than his wicked aim - has always
been his ability as a liar. In the main story,
he uses this ability in heartwarming ways,
like cheering up Kaya with his stories. In
the dark timeline, Usopp would use this
ability to bend others to his will and
trick them into doing his bidding: think a
long-nosed version of Johan from Monster,
who could get innocent people to commit
murder with just a short conversation.
With each of those Germa Snails
containing a battalion of giants,
the Evil Straw Hat Grand Fleet of Evil will be
sure to strike fear into every island across
the five seas of One Piece. And as for Usopp:
Master of Lies, children everywhere will fear
him. Parents will tell their kids that they
had better behave because the Devilish Sniper
King can hit a naughty person from anywhere in
the world. The only true words out of Usopp’s
mouth from this point on will be tales
of conquest, pillaging, and bloodlust.
But that bloodlust pales in comparison to the
next Straw Hat: Roronoa Zoro. Zoro is already
a savage swordsman with a secret heart of gold.
Take away that heart of gold and what do you
get? A true demon for the fighter and honorary
first mate of the Evil Straw Hats. For somebody
whose epithets range from “Pirate Hunter”
and just straight up the “King of Hell”,
he might just belong on the Evil Straw Hat
Crew ™ more than the normal Straw Hats.
Zoro never got to defeat his rival Kuina. Instead,
fate took his opportunity to become the strongest
away when Kuina died. In another timeline,
instead of taking her death with honor and
trying to achieve their shared dream for her sake,
Zoro would be consumed by rage. He would still try
to become the greatest swordsman, but instead
of honoring the tenets of the Bushido Code,
he would mercilessly cut down anyone in his
path on his quest to become the strongest.
And that will be perfect for his role as the
right hand man of the Evil Straw Hat Luffy.
Luffy grew up in terrible poverty. He saw
the difference between the Nobles and the
people who lived within the literal trash of the
Gray Terminal in his home in the Goa Kingdom. He
was abandoned by his own father. Shanks refused
to take him along as a pirate - in fact, if it
wasn’t for Shanks’ sacrifice of his arm, it’s very
easy to see how Luffy could have ended up much,
much different. He dealt with so much unfairness
and injustice. Before Shanks’ influence,
he thought that pirates should fight
back against the slightest grievance,
like when the Mountain Bandit
struck Shanks with a bottle.
What if Luffy was never taught that his tendency
for violence was wrong? That he should only fight
for things that are important, like to defend
the people he cares about? What if Luffy took
all of the injustice he faced in his childhood
and decided that he should just turn the world
upside down…I mean, he’s already an absolute
force of nature - causing absolute chaos for
the status quo on any island he travels to.
But this time, instead of the World Government
thinking he’s evil while in reality, he’s beloved
by the people of the world - in this timeline,
he’d strike fear into their hearts
just like Eustass Kid or Blackbeard.
Evil Luffy would probably look a lot like
Blackbeard, in fact - or act like him at least,
after all, Luffy drinks enough milk to keep
all his teeth. These two members of the Worst
Generation are pretty much two sides of the same
coin as it is. Just like Blackbeard, Luffy would
stop at nothing to achieve his dream of becoming
the Pirate King even if it means stomping all over
the dreams of other people. The way it is now,
Luffy lifts people up wherever he goes - this
Luffy would bring them down just like Blackbeard.
If Luffy was evil, he’d sell out anyone he needed
to: even if it was his own brother. In this
timeline, instead of Blackbeard turning in
Ace to become a Warlord, Luffy would be willing
to turn in his own brother to the marines if it
means climbing the ladder of the pirate world.
After all, Luffy is no hero - a hero is someone
who shares his meat. But as captain of the
Evil Straw Hats, he’d be a straight up villain.
Of course, if Luffy really was evil,
it’s unlikely his crew would ever join
him in the first place. More likely,
if Luffy had a sudden change of heart,
it would be up to the Straw Hats to stop
him from causing some serious harm to the
world. It just makes you wonder: is Gear 5
Luffy so broken that the other Straw Hats
wouldn’t even stand a chance against him even
with their combined strength? Or would they be
able to stop Luffy’s maniacal rampage? You’ll
just have to see how that battle shakes out
in this video where I talk about what would
happen if Luffy fought all of the Straw Hats.